my name is simon bowen i'm the assistant
harvard master here at ramscape so i've
been in that role for the last four and
a half years
the royal harbour is the crux of our
business here we have 450
births permanent yachts
in the inner and outer harbour in
addition we have another 250 births for
visiting yachts and in the summer those
can be full a lot of the time 200 years
ago
king george iv
was returning for the continent and
arrived at ramsgate
and received a
very very warm welcome from the
inhabitants of ramsgate when he was
returning
so as a reward he
gave us royal status on one of the
lighthouses
is a latin motto and you'll have to
excuse my latin it's it's not the best
but it's um
perfume miseries which actually means
refuge for those in need so ramsgate
became a refuge and it still is during
dunkirk
evacuation in 1940 80 000 um men came to
landscape from the beaches of dunkirk
over 4 000 small boats sailed backwards
and forwards to dunker so it has a
history of being a refuge and um
ramsgate um always
welcomes people and we always have done
as a harbour the architecture of the
harbour itself is absolutely lovely with
the arches which are all now um bars and
and
marine related um also i mean we have
pugin that lived in ramsgate and of
course he um did the interior of the
house house of parliament
and van gogh
lived here on spencer square so there's
some history there there's great
architecture in ramsgate itself in
addition to the magnificent beaches that
we've got
either side of the port which are
prevented by loads and loads of people
so it's a lovely lovely town with lots
of
amazing architecture